time now of course for the press preview
our first look at the front pages
uh over the remainder of the hour we'll
take a look at what's making the
headlines with the consultant editor of
the daily mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kevin mcguire
but first let's take you through the
front pages that we have starting with
the guardian
it reports that government ministers are
considering delaying the end of all
social distancing rules
due to the spread of the indian coveted
variant
all the times says the prime minister is
increasingly optimistic
that restrictions will end on june the
21st
now the home secretary pretty patel has
warned that those returning from
holidays in amberless countries can
expect a knock at the door
to check their self-isolating on their
return that according to the daily mail
i mean while the telegraph has seen the
findings of an official inquiry
into how the former bbc journalist
martin beshear secured that famous
interview with princess diana
it has apparently found that he used
deceitful methods
in breach of bbc guidelines
here's the metro it reports that whale
season tickets will be made flexible
from june the 21st
partly in response to more people
working both in the office
and at home a host of male celebrities
could face allegations
of sex abuse in the wake of those made
against the actor noel clark
and that's the lead story for the mirror
and attempts by chinese regulators to
restrict the use of cryptocurrency
has led to the price of bitcoin falling
by as much as 30
in recent days according to the ft
as you can see the boys are back andrew
and kevin here to take you through
their choice of the papers good to see
you both um
and because you've dressed up for the
occasion kevin let's start with you
shall we this morning
sorry i just had to do it i just had to
do it apologies um
the front of the daily telegraph and
their story in fact it's a story that's
appearing in quite a few of them uh
their headline
tells pretty much the story uh the probe
finds bbc's bashir
guilty of deceit yeah i know look um
andrew always looks smarter when he's at
home than when he goes out i just don't
know what's going on
on there yeah i'm a i'm a supporter of
the bbc a fan of the bbc and i'm a
republican but this
is a grade a starred crisis
for the bbc when lord dyson the former
master of the rules
concludes with his inquiry that 26 years
ago
deceit and rules were broken followed by
a cover-up
to persuade uh princess diana
to give an intimate interview to martin
beshear who resigned recently he
suffered very very ill health but he
also knew this
report was was coming out because the
bbc is a public
service broadcaster has an almost
semi-constitutional rule
with the with the royal family and how
is somebody like
prince william uh uh or prince charles
heirs to the throne gonna
react when they find that diana given
that interview
people who don't remember it and my
younger people might wonder what all the
fuss was about but this was an
absolute bombshell because she said
there were three people in her marriage
uh that uh charles was having an affair
with camille camilla parker bowser he's
since uh married that charles and diana
got divorced
and the subterfuge is alleged to have
included
fake bank accounts to make her think
that money was being
paid to a head of security of her her
brother earl
spencer who bashir persuaded
us to go between to get his sister to do
the interview that she was being
followed by the security services and
she was being
spied on and it could have induced a
paranoia could have
played as they could have played a role
in her
eventual death this is just a huge huge
scandal telegraph
say it's the equivalent of the the phone
hacking scandal which engulfed
newspapers uh suddenly my own uh two uh
and saw the closure of the news of the
world this
is absolutely major mega massive
it's not just bbc by the normal and all
the culprits
this is it's just so serious for the
corporation it can't be uh
it can't be overstated the the trouble
they could be in i mean
we should of course say andrew that that
of course martin beshear has
argued against the charges of wrongdoing
against him in fact in the the piece
itself it says that he's
understood to have mounted a vigorous
defense at the dyson inquiry but it
doesn't seem to have done much good
look this is extraordinary and the phone
hacking
scandal was a great day for many
newspapers
and uh some people went to prison and
have criminal records now if martin
beshear as lord dyson's reports
says did uh use counterfeit bank
statements to convince
princess of wales that she was being
that people
were being paid to spy on her they would
he was telling her that her protection
officer was spying on her he was telling
her that prince william
was spying on her he was feeding into
this vulnerable woman's
uh neurosis she was she was she was
vulnerable
her marriage was imploding she was the
most photographed woman in the world
and he exploited her at the most
appalling in the most appalling way
and if he has broken the law if there's
been any uh uh
suggestion ill that law has been broken
the police must be brought in
because that's what happened with
newspapers i'm not saying an eye for an
eye but
the bbc has to be held up to the very
highest possible
standard as kevin said it is the
national broadcaster
we pay for it with our license fee and
the other part of this thing which
stinks to high heaven is the cover-up
of bashir there was a very minor
investigation that was done the only
casualty
was a graphics designer who tony hall
who
who became later became the director
general uh
got rid of so tony hall who then became
lord hall he came back to the bbc as
director general the most powerful man
at the bbc
he's got serious questions to answer too
about the cover-up because cover-ups as
as you know often are almost not in this
case
but almost as bad as the original
offense so
those heads have to roll here uh bashir
has done the
so-called honorable thing in going off
with ill health but there are other very
serious people at the bbc
who've got a lot to answer not least
tony hall he was head of news at the
time
he he organized the inquiry
uh lord dyson says it was a cover-up uh
and uh i say and this poor guy the inter
the uh graphics designer
the only person who lost this job um
well it's a sorry day for the bbc
and apologies that have to be made and
my understanding is prince william is
going to have
quite a lot to say as will charles
spencer princess diana's brother
because he was due to by the bbc well of
course we will we await to see the
the full report when it's it is released
only the paper's getting uh early sign
up but i want to turn our attention i'm
kevin knight
to the front of the times and indeed the
front of the mail kind of
contrasting stories in the papers
everyone's looking forwards to the end
of lockdown but but it does seem to be
that it could perhaps be something of a
movable feast
yeah he's more even more cautiously
optimistic uh the prime minister
according to the time still the 1922
committee of tory mps today that
uh perhaps the uh indian variant
of uh covert 19 or the variant that was
first detected
in india isn't quite as transmissible as
was feared and matt hancock
the health secretary at the press
conference five o'clock today along with
jonathan van tan professor jonathan van
tan the deputy
uh chief medical officer will make
making the point that there has been no
increase in hospitalizations or deaths
as a result of this ovarian spread and
it has spread pretty
pretty rapidly there are nearly 3 000
cases now just looking at figures
figures here uh increased 28 in
two days main variant in many parts of
the country
however it is not making people
seriously ill so the vaccines may be
more effective than were feared against
it it's not filling hospitals
with people who are dying to figure what
uh three deaths
uh in the latest 24-hour period average
of eight
uh per day over the last the last week
which means
that come june 21st plans for
lockdown easing or almost uh abolishing
lockdown in england might go ahead the
guardian strikes a
slightly less optimistic tone or more
pessimism
and saying that freedom day may not be
as all embracing was was invisible it
could look like someone
yeah andre just take us we've got about
a minute before the break but take us to
the front of the daily mail
and their headline holiday police to to
knock on your door i mean
i suppose we should say that this this
is already going on it's just a scaling
up of this isn't it
yeah yeah i don't know that people are
knocking on doors
you're getting all these uh uh
irritating phone calls from people
checking that you are observing the
proper
uh rules for the quarantine but this is
suggesting that the actual police will
be knocking on your doors the
covered please if you like and this is
all part of the chaos that surrounds
uh whether you can go on holiday or not
because you've got a green list oh you
can go on holiday to green list
unless you're lord beth or the health
minister says no you can't even go on
holiday the green list countries
and i thought if you could go you could
go on holiday to an amber country
but the prime minister was very clear at
prime's question time today
you shouldn't but you can that's the
point uh and the law doesn't cover the
cleanest crystal andrew clean as crystal
well it's clear as mud clear as mud
actually
um chaps we are going to pause there and
take a very quick break we'll be back to
you for more afterwards uh where we'll
be discussing a
a possible reason for a holiday british
hedonism
is at a 22-year low more debauchery from
kevin and andrew
uh when we come back welcome back to the
press preview andrew and kevin
uh taking us through the papers this
evening and andrew story in the front of
the metro
um which they described just underneath
the headline is that the biggest real
shake-up in
in 25 years but you're perhaps slightly
more skeptical than i am
yeah i've been reading about these these
these shake-ups of railway tickets and
railway pricing for years chris grayling
known
university as failing grayling when he
was transport secretary was going to
make sure that ticket prices were
flexible that you didn't get wrecked
every time you
you traveled before 9 30. what's
happening in the next few days they're
going to announce
a whole new reform of the pricing
structure because when people go back to
work now because of david they're not
going to work necessarily a five-day
week
so that you're supposed to be able to
have what they're calling flexi season
tickets
maybe eight days on eight days off uh
and
it's going to be reflected in the price
but we've still got the most expensive
train fares
in europe they're among the dirtiest
trains in europe and they're often
amongst them the least punctual so um i
have
very little faith that the government's
going to deliver on this i hope they are
because i use trains quite a lot and
they're lousy
expensive and not very well run kevin a
quick thought from you and all of this i
mean the transport sector grant shaps is
certainly going to be banging on about
this as a major step forward
he is because he's uh he's sugar coating
what's quite a reverse by the government
creating great british railways which
could be a publicly owned
company will have the uh the
infrastructure which is network real now
it'll be collecting fares and having
much greater control over the entire
system which has been a complete private
sector
disaster train fares went up 2.6 this
year they've got 43
since 2010. the prices will will matter
there's no point having a flexi ticket
if you're still going to be fleece
enough to take out a mini mortgage in
order to get one
and but trying to put it all back
together after it was fragmented
in a disastrous privatization 100 broken
up 100 bits well
we've seen we're covered the the
companies of effectively private
companies have been taken over
some of them just walked away from
franchises in the past
because they couldn't make money you
want full public ownership restore it
run it in the public interest and that
includes
pricing in the public interest um of
course we three
are famed uh for our legendary sobriety
our ability to pass up parties at a
moment's notice so this
this story doesn't come as any surprise
the ft reporting andrew
that the country's undergoing a hedonism
hiatus not around my neck of the woods i
have to say
well apparently uh people like kevin
mcguire who um
uh uh wanted to let it all hang out and
now
are now thinking twice because of uh
covid
that we're um we're believing that we
that but
we've got to be so you've got to enjoy
life at the moment so hedonism
it's lowest level in britain for 22
years yet another consequence
of the pandemic i'm not sure it does
apply to gavin mcguire but i've always
led a very sedate moderate chaste life
anyway kevin are you currently letting
it all hang out which is the question on
everyone's lips at the moment thankfully
have you ever let it hang out looking
like that is it i mean
appointed with a clipboard to go knock
on your door to make sure you're
uh quarantining after coming from an
ambulance country but i
talk about just living for the day and
not worrying tomorrow
piercy tory boy lives for the minute
that's it
you know a forgetful goldfish going
around a ball
um kevin andrew we'll leave it there
before the lawyers get in touch i'll see
you again at
half past 11. good stuff this